- Last year it was the 25th
anniversary of "Clueless".
I know that you have had
to talk to about this film,
like I talk about "Since
You've Been Gone" in my career,
so I get that you're probably over it,
but I will say the very first
car I ever bought myself
was because of you.
- Did you get the white Jeep?
- And it was the white Jeep.
Yep, like everyone else.
I was not, I was a basic bitch.
(laughing)
But I was like I want that Jeep so badly.
But do you still keep up?
It was such a great
cast and a lot of y'all
gone to do so many amazing things.
So like, do you still keep
up with the castmates or no?
- We hadn't seen each other
in a really long time.
And then Donald Faison and Breckin Meyer
and Paul Rudd and I all went to Chicago
about a year ago or something.
And being, I was so lucky
to be with those three.
There they are, the Goofies.
- [Kelly] That's so awesome.
- They are so funny.
And they made fun of me a lot
because we all had to go on
stage to talk about the film
and Breckin and Donald were talking,
well, Donald was talking
about this birthday party
that he had and saying that I was there
and remember this and remember that.
And I didn't remember any of it.
And Paul Rudd at one point turned to me
'cause then he was
talking about another part
of the movie and he said,
were you even there?
Like, do you remember the movie?
- I said, I do, I do.
But I had the best time with those guys.
They're so funny and so sweet.
- But it's interesting that you say that
because I don't remember
everything either,
but it's, and you don't
know that you're gonna be
a part of one of the biggest
movies in pop culture.
You know, you don't know
that when you're shooting it.
You're not like, "I must hold onto this
"'cause this will, I will be talking
"about this in 30 years."
Like, you know what I'm saying?
You don't, you don't think like that
but it's such an unforgettable,
such a great movie.
- Thank you.
- So you have two movies,
two new movies coming out, so you're busy.
And can you tell us about them?
- Yeah, so one of them
is "(beep) Hits the Fan"
and another--
- Which is a great title.
- Yeah, I mean, it's really,
that's an interesting sort
of thriller film, sexy.
I can't wait to see that come together.
And then "The Requin"
which is an adventure
or more a survival kind of, with a shark.
- I am in.
- The requiem shark.
And I got so hurt making this movie
and it was so freezing cold
and it was so exciting.
It was the time of my life.
'Cause this director is incredible.
- Why did you get so hurt?
- Oh, 'cause I'm not in shape and--
- Oh, I am.
(laughing)
I'm so pristine.
- I'm not quite in shape.
I'm not an, it wasn't
like an, I didn't realize
that it was an action film
until I was doing it, you know?
And anyway, so that one is, I can't wait.
And then "Baby-Sitter's Club 2".
So I just finished shooting that, yeah.
- That's so cool.
So many cool nostalgic things.